PROFESSOR: Recursive data play
a key role in programming,
so let's take a mathematical
look at what goes on.
So the basic idea
of recursive data
is roughly that
you're going to define
a class of objects in
terms of the simpler
versions of the same object.
With a little more
precision, the idea
is that you [? can ?]
build up a recursive data
type by starting with some stuff
that you understand that's not
recursive and you give me some
base objects that I can begin
with and declare that they
belong to this recursive datum,
and then you give me some rules
called constructor rules which
enable me to build new
objects of the recursive type
by applying these constructors
to objects that I've already
built up.
There's nothing
circular about it
because I'm always
building up new stuff
from stuff I already have.
Let's look at an example.
I'm going to define
a set E that's
a subset of the
integers, and I'm
going to give you a recursive
definition of E. The base
case is that I'm going to
tell you that 0 is an E
and I'm going to give
you two constructors.
The first one says that if
you have an n that's an E,
you can add 2 to it and
get a new element in E,
providing that n
is not negative.
The second constructor is that
if you have an n that's an E,
you can negate it.
You can take minus n,
providing that n is positive,
and those are the two
constructor rules.
Well, let's look at
what goes on here.
What is this telling us?
Well, let's just use the
first constructor rule
and use it repeatedly.
I can start off with 0.
That's the base case, and then
I can apply the constructor
to add 2 to it.
Then I can apply the constructor
again to add 2 to 0 plus 2,
and then I can apply the
third time to get add 2 to 0
plus 2 plus 2.
And it's clear what I'm getting
is 0, 2, 4, 6, and so on,
and I'm going to get all of
the non-negative even numbers
in that way.
Now, I can apply to these,
the positive numbers,
I can apply the
negation constructor.
So I can get minus
2, minus 4, minus 6,
and it becomes apparent
then that I can
get all of the even numbers.
So we just figured out that
E contains the even numbers.
Is there anything else in E?
And the answer is
no, and the reason
is that an implicit part of the
understanding of a definition
like this is that the only
way that things can get into E
is by being a base case
or by being constructed
from previously
constructed elements
by applying the
constructor rules.
In other words, there's
an implicit clause here
that says that's all.
That implicit clause is
called the extremal clause.
And it's taken for granted and
rarely mentioned explicitly
as part of a
recursive definition,
but it's always
to be understood.
So what we can
conclude from this
is that E is exactly
the even integers
because there's nothing else
there except those ones that
were built up in
the way indicated.
So let's look at a slightly
more interesting example now.
I want to define the set
of strings that consists
only of left and
right parentheses
such that the left and
right parentheses match up.
Well, writing
parentheses on the slide
turns out to be confusing with
parentheses that are actually
used to delimit things, so I'm
going to replace parentheses
by brackets in blue-- a right
bracket and a left bracket.
This notation here,
by the way, stands
for the set of finite strings
of right and left brackets.
It's a general notation.
If you have some
collection of objects
which you think of as
letters and you write
an asterisk as a
superscript, that
means the finite strings
of those letters.
So these are the finite strings
of right and left brackets,
and I want to give a
recursive definition of a set
M which I plan will be
precisely those strings where
the left and right brackets
match up appropriately.
The way to think
about matching up
is take let's say a standard
arithmetic expression involving
plus and times and
so on, and make sure
that it's fully parenthesized.
So whenever you add
two things, there's
parentheses around
that, and whenever
you multiply two things,
there's parentheses
around that, meaning brackets.
Then if you erased everything
but the brackets, what
you'd be left with would be
a set of matched brackets.
Actually, it would be a
set of matched brackets
or you could have several
of them next to each other.
Those would still could
be considered matched,
so that's the way our
definition is going to behave.
Let's give it.
So the base case is about
the simplest it could be.
I'm going to start
with the empty string.
An empty string is this
thing that acts like a zero
under putting strings
next to each other,
or the concatenation operation.
If you concatenate the empty
string with any string,
it doesn't change the string.
And by definition,
then, the empty string
is a string with no
characters, has length zero,
and it acts as an identity
under putting strings
next to each other.
There's going to be one
constructor in M that's
slightly ingenious.
There's other maybe
simpler or more natural
ways to make up constructors
that would define M,
but this one is
particularly nice
because I can get
away with just one,
and it has some nice properties
that we'll explore later.
So here's the rule--
if I've built up
two strings s and t of matched
brackets that are in M,
then I can build a new one
by putting matched brackets
around s and concatenating
it with t-- that
is, if s and t are
strings of brackets in M,
then if I start with a
left bracket followed
by the brackets in s followed
by a right bracket followed
by the brackets in t, that new
string is yet another element
that I've built up in M.
Let's practice this
to see how it works.
So there's the
constructor again.
Well, how do I get started?
To start, all I have
is the base case.
s and t have to both be the
empty string because that's
the only thing available to
apply the constructor to.
So if I do that,
basically the s and the t
disappear in this
constructor expression
and all I'm left with is
a matching left and right
bracket.
But now I've got a matching
left and right bracket,
so I can use that to
apply the constructor to,
so I could let s be
the matching brackets
and t still be the empty string.
Now when I plug into
the constructor,
the t still disappears, but I
find brackets within brackets,
and that's another string
that I've built up in M.
Now, being methodical,
I could let s
be empty and t be the brackets.
And if I do that,
then the s goes away
and the t becomes the
matched pair of brackets
and I wind up with a matched
pair next to a matched pair.
Then, of course, I
could let both of them
be the matched brackets,
and then I get a nested pair
next to a matched pair.
And now that I've got also
going back to the very beginning
the next most
complicated string that I
had was the nested
pair of brackets,
I could let s be
that and t be empty,
and then I would get brackets
nested to depth three,
and so on.
That's the idea.
Now, it may or may
not be clear that you
get exactly the strings of
matched brackets in this way.
That's taken up further in the
notes and in some problems,
but we're just
trying to understand
how this definition works
and take it for granted
that, in fact, it's right.
Let's use that definition to
prove some things about M,
but I want to prove the things
based on the definition of M
not assuming that it
works as intended.
So I'm going to claim
based on the definition
that it's impossible to
find a string in M that
starts with a right bracket.
Now, of course,
since we're assuming
M is the right definition
of matched brackets,
it's clear that a string that
starts with a right bracket
already has nothing to match--
no left bracket matching it--
so it shouldn't be
in there, but let's
just make sure that the
definition behaves in the way
that we intend or
it might be wrong.
So how do I prove
that no string in M
starts with a right bracket?
Well, let's look
at the definition.
The base case doesn't
have any brackets at all,
so it certainly doesn't
start with a right bracket.
And looking at the constructor
rule, all the strings
that you can construct
start with a left bracket.
And so we're really appealing
to the implicit that's
all clause, the
extremal clause that
says that since the only
way to get things in M
is by applying the
constructor, you're
not going to be able
to get anything that
starts with a right bracket.
One more example of a
recursively-defined data type
that's interesting, and we'll
be doing some lovely class
problems with, is the class
that I call F18 functions.
These are the functions from
a first term of calculus,
like as you study
in 18.01, functions
of a single real variable, and
here's a recursive definition
that I think covers all
of the functions that
are considered in 18.01.
I'm going to start
off with the identity
function and any
constant function
and the function sine
of x, and declare
that those are the base cases.
Those are the functions in F18.
Then here are the
constructor rules.
If I have two functions
that are in F18,
I can add and multiply
them or take 2 to the f
where f is in there,
and those will all also
be functions in F18.
So I can start
building up a bunch
of interesting stuff like
polynomials and exponentials.
In addition, if I have a
function that's in F18,
I can take it's inverse--
at least, insofar
as the inverse is
defined in the function--
and I can also compose
two functions that
are in F18 to get another one.
Let's look at how
this definition works.
I claim that, in fact, the
function minus x is in F18.
How do I build up
minus x from the rules?
Well, minus 1 is a constant
function, so I have that.
And x is just the
identity function,
and I can multiply two
functions that I have.
So if I multiply minus
1 times x, guess what?
I got minus x, so
I've just figured out
that that function is in F18.
What about the square root of x?
Well, if I multiply
the identity by itself,
I get the function x squared.
And then if I take its inverse,
that's square root of x.
Well, I gave you sine x, but
not cosine x or any other trig
functions.
Why not?
Well, I want them all, but I can
get them by the rules already.
So how do you get cosine x?
Well, cosine x is just
sine of x plus pi.
Well, why is that in there?
Pi is a constant,
x is the identity.
So the sum is a
function that's in F18.
And then if I compose
that function with sine,
I get sine of x plus
pi, which is cosine x.
So cosine x is there.
Now, this was actually
pointed out to me
by students, this simple
way of getting cosine x.
The original way
that I thought, and I
was using that square
root operation where
I was going to use the
identity that cosine squared
plus sine squared is equal to 1.
So if I take 1 minus sine
squared and then take
the square root, that's another
way to get cosine x, the point
being that there's a
lot of ways to derive
the same function as
being in F18 built up
from the operations
applied to other functions.
What about log of x?
Let's just close with that.
How do I get log of x?
Well, log of x is the
inverse of e of the x.
How do I get e to the x?
Well, e to the x is
what you get by taking 2
to the log to the base
2 of e, which is e,
and then raising
that to the power x.
So if I take log e, which is
a constant log to the base 2
of e, which is a
constant, I multiply it
by x the identity function
and I take 2 to that power,
I'm composing, in other words,
x log x with the constructor 2
to the F, then I wind up
with the function e to the x.
And when I take its inverse,
I get log of x, as claimed.